AND CALLING THIS FOR THE FLAMES
PLAYS REALLY GOOD FOR THE MOST
LEADS THE PLAY AND THEY JUST PUT
IT ON NET B
AND BACK TO BONINO.
MAKES A PASS TO BONINO. ALL ARO
THE PUCK IN DEEP A THIS TEAM FO
GRANTED AND INCLUDING A GREAT
LINE.
HERTL JUST INSIDE THE ZONE.
>> Cassie: AND VLASIC REALLY
THROWS THITRAFFIC. AUCER A PASS
>> BACK LUND'S
FLIPS IT TO GUDBRANSON.
HE STOPS THE SHARPRIED TO TIP T
AND PUT IT WIDE ON THE  YOUNGST
IN IT BUT WHEN YOU HAVE SO MANY
OFFICIAL SHOT FROM BURNS OFF HIS
MARKSTROM STRUGGLED WITH IT AND
MEIER JUST RECOGNIZES THAT HE'S
A LITTLE
KNOCKED AWAY BY BURNS.
THERE'S A SHOT AND THA
DEFENSIVE ZONE.
YOU THE INITIAL
SAVE BY MARKSTROM AND THERE'S
WIDE.
AND THE